قد يكون الهجوم الصيني على تايوان ان حصل
احد اخطر الاحداث في القرن الحادي
والعشرين ليس ذلك فقط بل ان الحرب
الاوكرانيه التي اربكت العالم ستكون حادثا
عرضيا من حيث التداعيات المحتمله لكن ما
هو السيناريو المتوقع لهذه الحرب
لم تطلق الصين غزوا مباشرا وعلى حين غره
اذ يحتاج الهجوم تجمعا يستغرق اسابيع امر
سيكون تحت مراه ومسمع اقمار التجسس
الغربيه
ستلجا الى الحصار الخيار الابطئ والخفي
ابتداء بمناورات عسكريه قد تطول لتتحول
الى حظر جوي وبحري تقيس من خلاله الصين رد
فعل العالم و واشنطن ومدى استعدادها
للمواجهه تدعي الصين ان تايوان جزء من
اراضيها وتتعهد باستعادتها حتى وان لجات
الى استخدام القوه لاخضاع الجزيره
المحكومه بنقاط ضعف تثير شهيه بكين لغزوها
فالقوه الدفاعيه العظيمه للتايوان هي
موقعها الجغرافي كجزيره مفصوله عن البر
الرئيسي بمضيق عاصف يبلغ عرضه 100 ميل لكن
ذلك في الوقت نفسه نقطه ضعفها الكبير وعلى
عكس اوكرانيا التي لها حدود بريه طويله مع
خمس دول اوروبيه تعتمد تايوان على اعاده
الامتداد واعاده التسلح في البحر والجو
واغلاق هذه الطرق سيكون بنفس اهميه الغزو
البرمائي تقول التوقعات ان السيناريو
الغزو الصيني ليس مهما بقدر ما سيكون من
الاهميه لتداعياته غزو قد يجتذب اليابان
وكوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده ودول
النيت الاخرى وربما
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات